première cérémonie de voeux en ce 7
janvier pour le nouveau maire de magny
les hameaux et du beau monde pour
écouter le discours du socialiste
bertrand où ils ont élu en septembre
dernier après le départ de jacques
lolliot en poste depuis 1995 ministre
député maire de sa couleur politique
étaient présents pour ce baptême du feu
à nouveau maire nouvelle activité
curiosité peut-être curiosité mais aussi
lucidité si les socialistes se montrent
aussi mobilisés c'est sans doute car
magny les hameaux attise les convoitises
l'ump espère bien conquérir la ville aux
municipales de mars 2014
valérie pécresse était d'ailleurs
présente comme de nombreux élus
yvelinois de droite et entendent faire
basculer l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines qui a toujours été
détenues par la gauche
on peut aussi gagner à des communes sur
la droite dans cette agglo à elancourt
en particulier sur lesquelles on va
mettre beaucoup de moyens donc manie
n'est pas un cas particulier pour nous
c'est simplement une ville à conforter
c'est à la fois un soutien amical
et puis politique aussi pour lui dire qu
il peut évidemment compter sur un ou
tous les municipales au coeur des
discussions de couloir lors de cette
soirée est la rumeur d'une candidature
de benoît hamon sur la liste de guy
malandain rattrape qui se fait de plus
en plus insistantes
je n'ai pas encore discuté à guy
malandain si vous le proposons en
discutera mais pour l'instant
on n'a pas encore parlé